good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Wednesday happy hump day
I'm so sad that Claudia is not here to
remind you to hump someone you love but
in her stead we have such an exciting
guest co-host that I know the toasters
are truly going to plots over so please
help me in welcoming dumwa to the toast
[Laughter]
hi thank you for having me I'm so happy
to be here thank you so much I am so
excited that you're on the toast I know
the toasters are going to be so excited
you've never been on before but we are
such fans of yours obviously and I'm so
excited to get your Take On Pop Culture
you just wrote a book called A
non-please which I've been reading and
it's so good it's just like one of those
books that's like girly girl in New York
City but it's also pretty much your
story correct
yeah like a lot of it was based
hold on one sec sorry
excuse me a lot of it was based on
things that actually have happened to me
and I would say like 80 of the
characters are inspired by real people
either celebrities or real people in my
life right and I think a lot of the fun
of the book is trying to figure out
which celebrity in the book like who
they are in real life but I kind of
realized I feel like they're kind of a
conglomerate of people like composite
characters
so yes some are yeah some are um a
combination of people but some are like
straight up inspired by just like one
person I feel like there's some that are
obvious and then there's some that like
you kind of have to figure out yeah
um but yeah so
I don't know how much I'm allowed to say
like legal would like you know Thrill Me
Right like you have to change this you
have to change that I'm like why it's
fiction right were there instances where
you wanted to use real names but you
just could not
I think for the characters that had like
big story lines I knew we had to change
the name yeah but they're they're all
based on actual celebrities so and the
things that you've read and saw and
heard over the years
yeah and things that like my account has
posted or like I've been involved in or
you know what was going on behind the
scenes when like this story broke right
stuff like that so so cool well I'm
enjoying it immensely and we'll get to
more book talk a little later in the
show so we're gonna do the Fast Five
together I don't think I could have a
more expert opinion here on the stories
of the day but I also there's this
conspiracy going around that Claudia is
dumois she did an April Fool's joke
about it which was so funny and I
actually feel like this episode is
feeding that conspiracy because like why
couldn't Claudia be here she's not here
she's not here no one has ever heard
Claudia dumois on the same podcast or
seen them in the same room so I just
feel like this episode might lead people
to believe even more than ever that
Claudia is dumwa
okay well I mean I'm not as funny as
Claudia which like kind of is giving me
like anxiety because she's so [ __ ]
funny so funny I know I like I see the
clips I mean I used to listen to you
guys when it was the breath good times
good times yeah
um so she's just so funny so hopefully
I'll be able to live up to that standard
I think you're gonna be amazing Claudia
I miss you in studio I hope you're doing
well today I actually Wonder like who do
most people think you are like what's
the biggest theory about who you are
there was a time this is so random but
people were convinced I was that girl
from NYC prep remember so yes oh my God
that's a really good guess yeah they
were like convinced I was Jesse then you
know some people did think I was Claudia
to which I just said like you can't run
like two big Accounts at the same time
no no but people really thought that
like
Claudia was doing both or I forget who
else they thought someone else with a
big platform and I was like you can't do
both at the same time it's like
virtually impossible it's so true I feel
like that's one of the biggest things I
got from reading your book is like how
much time like and how much it just like
sucks you into this Vortex how much you
need to be on your phone like and
in order to do the job you know do you
ever feel like you're just like on I'm
sure by now you've maintained a really
good balance but I'm sure at the
beginning it was just like your whole
world is on your phone and like people
are wanting to hear from you and so if
you spend a few hours doing something
else it's like you got to get back to
the phone
that is so true like you nailed it and I
still do feel that way if I'm like away
from my phone for like a couple hours
like let's say I'm like at a dinner or
like in a movie like I start getting
anxiety like as time's ticking because
I'm like what's going on on my phone
right like what's going on
um but yeah in the beginning it was like
really bad like I couldn't leave my
phone anywhere if I was at like a family
dinner I'd be like looking at it under
the table like seeing if I was getting
any like Hot Tips right and then you
also you must have like anxiety too
about wanting to check your phone when
you're at a restaurant or something but
then not wanting anyone to see it
because you want to maintain this
anonymity
right so like that moment when I step in
the Uber like at the end of a night is
like such a moment of relief because I'm
alone in the Uber no one's around me
looking over my shoulder and I could
check like what's been going on like for
the past couple hours but yeah I still
get that feeling I don't think it's ever
going to go away I think it's it's
almost like a rush a little bit too oh
for sure yeah so I don't mind it but I
have been trying to spend less time on
my phone because like in the beginning
and that's like when the book takes
place I was literally on like probably I
don't even know 12 hours a day maybe
more I was gonna ask what is your screen
time when you get your weekly update
yeah I haven't looked in a while I think
it's a lot less now because I'm trying
to like be better yeah and plus I have
like other responsibilities that have to
do with the brand but aren't on
Instagram so like recording like today
like you know like I'm not going to be
able to check my phone for the next hour
like who knows what's gonna happen like
what's breaking right now yeah Arielle
charney's story yes we're gonna talk
about it in the fast times I wasn't sure
right now the Business Insider story
hasn't come out and you're kind of the
only source that has spoken about it yet
so I just want to know like what you've
heard because you're here today which is
so fortuitous so we'll get into that uh
in the stories but I guess while we're
recording yeah that might be the thing
that breaks who knows yeah
more information yeah yeah so I'm so
excited that you're here today and I
guess without further uh did it did it
do let's get into the fast five stories
that you without further ado demois
[Laughter]
here are the fast five stories that you
all need to know this morning and dumwa
is going to tell us like the real behind
the scenes [ __ ] that's going on with
some of the people that we talk about
every single day so I am so excited I
have a question for you before we get
into the stories do you ever get tired
of talking about pop culture
yes and do you like be alive yes because
you're a pop culture expert and curator
that like that's people's go-to
conversation topic with you and you're
just like I'm off the clock
[Music]
um sometimes it depends like who I'm
with like honestly my family does not
give a [ __ ] like they could care less
um certain friends are into it and
certain friends don't care so it depends
like who I'm with but yeah I get tired
of talking about it and I get tired of
talking about the same people
um and like to be honest like I don't
know if this is gonna shock people I
probably shouldn't say this but like I
really don't care like that's not my
favorite part of my platform my favorite
part of my platform is the people like
the followers yeah like the audience and
interacting with the people and like
things that have nothing to do with pop
culture is my favorite part so like I
totally agree with you and I feel like
we're in a similar boat where it's like
the business so much about pop culture
and that's how things like started but
now the things that like bring you Joy
are some of the things that have come
from that initial interest in pop
culture exactly exactly and I don't
think I'm an expert like I know I don't
know [ __ ] like there's people out there
that know everything yeah you know I'm
just like doing my best like trying to
like filter the information and get
people the information they want but I
think you are providing those people who
know everything like you're one of their
main sources to know everything and
catalog it in their minds so yeah yeah I
think they they get excited and they're
happy like when they tell me something
and then I post it like I'm talking
about the pop culture people who are on
like Reddit and Tumblr and Twitter like
oh yeah they know the information and
I'm not telling them anything new but
they just like to see it like I guess
posted which I'm happy to provide I'm
happy to provide that service right and
a lot about a lot of the stuff in your
book is about like how you verify tips
and what kind of tips you will post and
won't post and I imagine that's one of
the hardest lines that you walk in your
job so what is your policy really when
you get a tip that could be true could
be false
I mean if it's anything litigious
automatically I will not post it because
I'm not like looking to get like a cease
and desist or like you know get
entangled in any like litigious
situations with celebrities so that
automatically I won't post anything
about somebody's sexual orientation
unless they talk about it themselves I
won't post if it's not known and I do
get a lot of that
um and then you know I try not to post
anything about anyone under the age of
18. that's a good um you know
everybody's asking about Jenna Ortega I
think she's 20 but still she's like
still like at that age that's like
pretty young I don't feel like you know
a gossip Instagram account is probably
like the best place for somebody that
young to be you know talked about yeah
so I try to like keep that in mind like
young people's Mental Health
um but it's hard because like the show's
so popular every day everybody's like
who's Jenna Ortega dating like I want to
hear more about Jenna Ortega and it's
like nothing bad but I just feel like
it's probably best to just like let the
young people deal with the issues
they're already dealing with besides
being talked about on Instagram so yeah
I feel like you have such a good pulse
on like who's coming up like if if the
celebrities were like the stock market
like whose stock is rising who's falling
based on like what people are looking to
you on information for and also like
what tips are coming in I feel like
there are certain celebrities who get so
many tips about and you're like wow
people love this person yeah for sure I
mean Jenna Ortega is like one of them I
actually named her as someone who like I
would want to play the main character in
my book that was one of my questions
yeah because and I thought this before
Wednesday I thought it from her
performance in you I really liked her
performance in you so I was like she'd
be perfect to play cricket that's the
main character in the book
um but I don't know if that's gonna
happen and for your listeners who don't
know the book has been purchased by HBO
Max yeah and it's going to be a one hour
drama series oh wow I didn't realize it
was gonna be one hour series I oh so oh
so it's a like a whole show yes yeah oh
my God that's so exciting has there been
any casting developments that you can
share
um no casting developments right now
they're trying to sign on a writer and
the writer that they're speaking to I
don't know if it's official yet is so
exciting so if that becomes official and
I can announce it it's like gonna be
really cool so I think they need to like
sign on the writer they have the
producer sign on the writer and then I
guess they'll start like casting and
talking about like the story I'm I don't
know if they're gonna change the book a
lot I don't know like what their plans
are but is it so crazy that a few years
ago like you would be telling that story
about like a different show like what
writer signed on and who's in talks are
casting and now like you're doing that
about your own story yeah like I can't
wait till the show starts filming like
am I gonna like gossip about it like I
don't know like maybe I will like a
Showman's
yeah show man's like I I mean I hope
there's like nothing bad that happens on
set but like maybe someone's gonna be
difficult or unhappy like oh my God
that's so crazy do you are you the type
that would want to be have like a little
Cameo on your show like even if it's
just like being a
like a receptionist or something no no
absolutely not oh I guess it doesn't no
sorry that doesn't work for you because
you are extremely Anonymous but I'm just
like thinking
that I would do
yeah I just like I I'm I actually am an
executive producer on the show for the
show I don't know like what that entails
or how much they'll let me like really
do but a cameo is not on my list of
requirements of requirements yeah I
understand that completely well that's
really exciting the book you can like
see it as a show already and I think
that's going to be awesome so
congratulations on all of that and thank
you is the show going to be called a
non-please also
I I think so I'm not sure I'm it's up to
up to the producers but I think it might
be yeah the bigwigs
the Big Wigs yep okay well let's get
into the stories finally I'm sure I'll
bombard you with questions throughout
today's episode is brought to you by
fashion pass we know so many of you guys
already know and love fashion pass it is
the steeniest clothing rental service
steam tested steam approved you get
unlimited rentals for one flat price so
if you don't know fashion pass or you've
heard us talk about it and you're
listening with bigger ears today this is
the time to sign up for fashion pass it
is a clothing rental service but unlike
some of the other ones out there they
have cute ass [ __ ] this season is the
time where we have so many events
holidays holiday parties and you need
outfits and you need fresh outfits that
are this season that you're only really
going to wear once and so renting them
makes so much sense you obviously want
to look sickening everywhere you go but
that gets expensive when you want a new
outfit for every event you don't want to
be Lizzie McGuire an outfit repeater why
would you spend 200 on one outfit when
you could rent unlimited pieces for
thirty nine dollars you save so much
money because you're not buying new
clothes all the time and you're being a
very economical and stylish at the same
time they have the best Brands like for
love and lemons free people show me your
MooMoo Amanda up Richard and so many
more these are brands that I love so
much one of my favorite Parts about it
is that if you love something and want
to keep it you get a huge discount when
you buy it anywhere between 30 and 60
off honestly I use fashion pass as a
clothing rental service but I wind up
buying so many of the items because I
love them and I do want to wear them
again but it's perfect because if you
want to wear it again you have the
option to buy it and if you're a one and
done with it you can
give it back to Fashion pass if you're
not into renting or you just want to
purchase something you can actually buy
anything on their site right now even if
you're not a member it's basically like
Poshmark but better because everything
is in like new condition and it's so
easy to browse the site for whatever
you're looking for they offer free
shipping and returns and it's super easy
you can purchase brand new items or buy
like new items for huge discounts up to
70 off which is amazing we actually have
a special discount code for you today
it's their biggest discount ever if you
go to fashionpass.com and use code toast
at checkout you'll get 50 off your first
month so you can try it for literally 39
that's unlimited rentals for just 39
with code toast do not sleep on fashion
pass especially this holiday season you
want options and you want your options
now so that's fashionpass.com code toast
today's episode is also brought to you
by seed because it's the holiday season
and you've got places to go and you do
not need stomach issues turns out
everything that you think you know about
probiotics might be wrong yeah probiotic
tortilla chips sound way too good to be
true and they probably are but you know
what's not too good to be true seeds
ds01 daily symbiotic it is the real deal
so what is a daily symbiotic I'm so glad
you asked I personally did not know
until we started working with seed but
it is a broad spectrum two in one
probiotic and Prebiotic it is 24 strain
broad spectrum probiotic and Prebiotic
formulated for Digestive gut immune and
additional systemic benefits so in
layman's terms it's going to help you
make a big soft Duty and here at the
toast we are BSD inclined
it is a capsule in a capsule which
protects against stomach acid digestion
enzymes and bile salts for viability
through digestions what does it mean the
live probiotics will actually make it to
the end of the small intestine for
delivery into the colon again seed has
worried about all of these technical
terms so that you can just worry about
that big Duty
that you're gonna make okay it is what
it is you guys and if I'm saying it like
it's [ __ ] the truth so don't get
backed up this holiday season start
using seed now I all jokes aside I was
having some really weird stomach pains a
few weeks ago nothing crazy nepharettes
just nefarious just discomfort and I
could tell that like things weren't
working as they should be and I had
fallen off on my seed usage so I went
back to using it every single day and
prioritizing taking seed and it has been
amazing I am
I know this is TMI but I'm reading the
ads today so I'm regular and I'm feeling
good and I want everyone else to feel
the same so start a new healthy habit
today visit seed.com toast and use code
toast to redeem 20 off your first month
of seeds ds01 daily symbiotic that's
seed.com toast and use code toast you
guys you will not regret this but our
first story of the day is a dumwa
original because you have reported a few
times on your Instagram stories based on
tips that you've received that a story
is coming out about blogger Arielle
charnis and her husband and her business
is supposed to drop today I'm checking
news feed again it hasn't yet what have
you heard and what do you know well I'm
so happy we're talking about this so
when does this episode come out right
after this like as soon as we're oh my
God this is oh my God this is perfect
okay because everyone's in my DMs
like don't leave us hanging like give us
more information and first of all I was
receiving tips about this like until
like 1am last night like it was just
like rolling in and basically it's all
the same information and
all this information can also be found
on Reddit like I wasn't the one to
uncover any of this like I don't like to
take credit where credit is not due all
this information was on Reddit so people
were talking about this on Reddit some
people started messaging me about it and
my response was I don't like to talk
about influencers because I feel like
we're all kind of in the same space so
they're kind of like colleagues right
right I kind of just like to leave that
alone but then it got to the point where
so many people were asking me about it
like I had no choice like I had to
address it or else you know what's the
point of my account so
there is a part of the story that I
really don't feel comfortable repeating
okay and that's something to do with
their personal relationship
um I'm sure that your listeners who have
been following on Reddit know what I'm
talking about but that's like their
personal business and I'm not talking
about divorce that's also a rumor that
like they're gonna get divorced now some
people have suggested that they might
get divorced
um to save face for like whatever's
going on legally got it
um because they're they're showing like
a united front on Instagram like he's
commenting on her Instagram posts she's
posting like everything's copacetic so
they are showing a united front so I
think that those rumors like the divorce
rumors like put on the back burner for
now
what everyone is talking about is that
allegedly Brandon charnis embezzled four
to five million dollars from investors
people who invested in the something
Navy brand embezzled this money for
personal personal use and he got caught
and I haven't posted this but I'm happy
to say and I probably won't post it so
this is the only place you'll hear
somebody messaged me late last night
that he got arrested in Florida I don't
know if that's true that's what I was
hearing like rumors said he asked many
people were saying he's getting arrested
tonight this morning they're like you
got arrested last night but wouldn't
that be like on TMZ already and in the
legal filings or no I don't know I think
an arrest you can like just like a
marriage certificate or a birth
certificate you could probably look up
an arrest so I don't know that's a great
question but I heard this late last
night from somebody who
um said that their Source was like Rock
Solid that he got arrested in Florida
she's in New York you know just going
about her Daily Business like everything
is okay she was at the polo bar last
night people were messaging me from the
Polo Bar like people that were sitting
near her saying that like she was with
her sister she looked like everything
was okay there were rumors that he got
arrested at the polo bar but he wasn't
there so those rumors are not true got
it and then she posted because I feel
like they're putting up a
or maybe it seems like they're putting
up a united front like on his end but
her content has been very like her
Centric like is she commenting on his
stuff like it it seems like he might be
in the doghouse and he's trying to look
like they're okay but she's like I don't
know him
yeah I think he probably is in the
doghouse for a variety of reasons one
being like the personal part that I
don't feel comfortable talking about
because I don't know if it's true it's
rumors about their marriage and I have
to say these rumors like for the people
who know what I'm talking about they
have been going around for the past like
three years they're not new people who
went to college with him like do you
know what I'm talking about I do I do
yeah people who went to college with him
said the same thing people were
messaging me these rumors three years
ago
um so maybe she's like maybe their
rumors are true and she's pissed or like
the rumors are true and they've been
true but everybody kind of has a
different like situation in their
marriage and maybe they found something
that like works for them even if to
other people it might not be
conventional I'm sure you see a ton of
that in your DMs like what percent of
celebrity relationships which you say
are actually monogamous and like
intentionally monogamous
uh 10
15 that's and everyone else like has
some sort of arrangement where it's like
you know monogamy isn't natural but
you're my chosen partner and blah blah
blah yeah I think they either have like
an arrangement to have like an open
marriage and I heard this actually from
a very reliable source like a lot of
couples a lot of married couples when
when the husband or wife is away on set
it's like anything goes and then they
come whatever happens like whatever
happens on set stays on set and then
they come back to their like married
life like nothing ever happened but the
wife or husband knows that they're like
filming these movies and like [ __ ]
around in their trailer I heard that
that's a very reliable source that kind
of makes sense to me because then also
where those instances where the public
finds out about it but then the spouse
stands by their partner and we're just
like how could you and it's like these
people are not like
ordinary lay people who expect their
partner to be like monogamous exactly so
I think we need to take that into
consideration and not use judgment and
who cares if it worked like you said if
it works for them that's like their
business right so okay I guess that's
what's to come with the Chargers yeah
yeah so there's a recording going around
have you heard it no I haven't heard I
haven't heard about it what is the
content there's a recording going around
of this guy okay I don't know who he is
I'm like trying to find out who he is
um it's posted on Tick Tock and I think
on Reddit and he's literally like
confirming all the rumors that we've
been hearing like but he's speaking like
into a voice memo and at the end he
mentioned something about Cold Spring
Harbor
I don't it's like very it's kind of like
fuzzy at the end but he mentioned
something about that
um so I don't know if like that's where
he's from or like they know people there
that these rumors are being confirmed by
but
I highly recommend you get your hands on
it and listen but it's just a guy
talking it's a guy talking being like
um I met Ariel and Brandon charnis five
years ago
um the rumors about him embezzling he
embezzled four to five million like and
then it gets into the personal stuff
like how he I guess I could say this
because I talk about this a lot on how
he was attending like an underground sex
club a lot
it's very I could send it to you it's
very but this guy could be you know
random off like nobody who doesn't know
anything well that's what I thought but
that's why I mentioned like Cold Spring
Harbor because like at the end he like
mentioned something about Cold Spring
Harbor and like I don't know like are
there trolls living in Cold Spring
Harbor I feel like that's like a print
like who in Cold Spring harm or is like
trolling the internet I don't know it
sounded legit is what I'm gonna say okay
well we shall see what's to come the
article is supposed to drop today but is
it going to drop today what have you
heard about that
um I heard it was delayed because of of
all this like like drama around the
rumors and like it getting out so I
heard it's delayed which I knew was
gonna happen I knew like once The Tick
Tock started rolling out and you know
once people started posting about it on
Instagram I knew the article was going
to be delayed because that's how you
know yeah that's how they work so it's
delayed because like now we think more
tips are coming in because more people
are knowing about it I think they're
getting more information
I think they're they're Gathering more
information and
um it I heard Thursday Friday maybe next
week I don't know we'll see I think
listen somebody sent me an email from
somebody a Business Insider looking for
information I was gonna just I saw that
on your Instagram story this morning I
was wondering if that was sent to you no
it wasn't sent to me that's like a good
clarification I'm glad you asked it was
not sent to me it was sent to somebody
else who sent it to me who said I could
post it so the so business The Business
Insider article is true
got it and so in what's in the article
it's like it's really he was [ __ ]
around whatever in his personal life he
was uh allegedly embezzling money like
it's it's all on him correct
yes I don't know if they'll address like
the personal aspect of it but apparently
yes he embezzled four to five million
dollars from
whoever his investors were I think they
got a 10 million dollar yeah investment
that was like big news when it happened
a few years ago yeah they got a 10
million dollar investment in 2019 so
like I was like asking my friend I'm
like how does embezzlement work do they
just like take some of that 10 million
dollars and like go on vacation and like
say it was a business expense like I I
guess that's what happened yeah but
she's not based on what you've heard
like she's not culpable like he is I
don't know it might be like a Teresa
good DJ situation do you know what I
mean like yeah yeah that's what I think
it is so she could be
she could be responsible for the
misappropriation of these funds like and
it's her I mean it's her business so
it's not like with Teresa it was Joe's
business and she's not like a
businesswoman but this is Ariel's
business and so you would hope that she
would have visibility into things that
are going on in it I mean who knows
maybe her husband was just like sick
we're getting 10 million dollars like
sign here and she was like okay like I
don't know you know yeah but she's
posting as if the sun is shining except
she has a very
dark uh filter feed going on right now
that's the aesthetic the kids are doing
oh well I think that she probably hired
like a crisis PR person and they told
her just act like everything's fine
that's like what I think I think that's
good advice I think that if she didn't
post right now anything it would give
more like uh oxygen to these rumors it
would prove some sort of guilt I don't
think there's anything she could do
right now other than act like
everything's normal right and I feel bad
for her kids and you know I've actually
never heard like anything too terrible
about her
um she seems like a nice person so she
does the whole story really gives me a
pit I and I feel like there's so much
shot in Freud going on and it just like
makes me sad like this is a family and
if this was her business it's one thing
for your husband to
disappoint you in in your marriage but
it's another it's a doubly disappointing
for him to then destroy your business
and like what a business she's built
well that's what I was asking someone
like do people still buy her clothes
like I need to know like who the hell is
walking around in her clothes well I
think her business became her designing
her own clothes plus her being a
retailer and selling plenty of other
designers like I get targeted ads for
her shop all the time and like because I
think it's actually pretty smart because
she has really nice taste and clothes so
it's like she's a designer and a curator
but I didn't realize that I don't know
who is going into the brick and mortar
shops or going to her website I don't
know
right I don't know either
um I don't think I've ever met anyone
who's purchased an item of clothing but
I know her style and her vibe is like
really popular yeah and like even if she
just stuck to making money from her
Instagram alone like she could live well
I'm sure I I think she could live well
but not how they are currently living
the way that they're currently living is
on a whole nother level exactly and I
said to somebody like that four to five
million dollar rumor that's going around
that makes sense for the type of
lifestyle that they are showing like
that's this that's the number like it's
it's just enough to live like they're
living but not too much and not too
little like I agree with that yes so if
anybody wants to embezzle money like
four to four to five million is like
we'll get you we'll get you a great The
Sweet Life yeah exactly
um so yeah we'll see what happens with
that and ordinarily like today if who
quality were here we probably wouldn't
have spoken about it because there's not
like a
story and now you have provided all this
other Clarity so that's why I'm glad
you're here today but until this story
drops I feel like we're all just yeah we
don't know it's all speculation but I
also feel like you can sift through the
tips that you get and like at this point
you probably know what's the truth
well I mean I did have some people who
have verified their relation to the
situation
who have right confirmed
some of the rumors so yes and I'm and I
just want to say like I'm receiving DMs
like people are coming forward from
their real accounts and talking about
this like I'm not getting like anonymous
tips
um it's really funny when like something
like this happens especially in New York
New York is really a small place so and
all my followers a lot of them are from
New York so
I'm getting a lot of information about
this is my point for that reason yeah I
imagine you are
which is why you're the go-to the go-to
girly
before we continue I've got to let you
know that today's episode is also
brought to you by better help so
unfortunately life does not come with a
user manual and when it's not working
for you it's normal to feel stuck and
it's hard to know where to turn at that
time which is why we are so excited to
tell you about betterhelp if you don't
know about it yet navigating life's
challenges can make you feel unsure
whether it's a career change a new
relationship becoming a parent or the
holiday season itself yes there's so
much holiday Joy this season but can
also be isolating and bring up sad
feelings and you might want someone to
talk to about it which is why betterhelp
is a wonderful resource the therapists
there are trained to help you figure out
the cause of challenging emotions and
learn productive coping skills this
makes therapy the closest thing to a
guided tour of the complex engine called
you wow I've never thought about that
but you are a complex engine and
sometimes you need a little service in
it is what it is
we love better help here at the toast
It's a Wonderful resource they have so
many licensed therapists if you find
someone that's great for you great if
you want to switch it up it's so easy to
do that with better help as the world's
largest therapy service better help us
match three million people with
professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
if things aren't clicking you can easily
switch to a new therapist anytime it
couldn't be simpler we love that no
waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist learn
more and save 10 off your first month at
betterhelp which is you can go to
betterhelp.com toast that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash toast again a
wonderful resource for getting your
mental health in check especially at
this time of year
and today's episode is also brought to
you by neutrifold you guys we have been
talking about hair so much on the toes
one we're just girls with hair like hair
and want strong hair and you know what
I'm not gonna lie this hasn't been my
year for hair growth until I started
using neutrophone again so I used
neutrophil a few years ago when I cut my
hair short which I was loving life it
was so amazing but then I was like you
know what I'm ready for Rapid hair
growth and I want to kick it up a notch
so I used neutrophil then and then once
I started experiencing postpartum hair
loss this year I started using
neutrophone again because not only did I
love the way it worked the first time
but I had heard so many great amazing
endorsements from people that I trust
and that I know even the salon that I go
to they have it that I was just there
yesterday yeah I go to the salon and
they had neutrophil there and the woman
was talking about how amazing it is I
was like I know girl I know so it is the
number one dermatologist recommended
hair growth supplement clinically shown
to improve your hair growth thickness
and and visible scalp coverage
neutrophil supports healthy hair growth
from within by targeting the five root
causes of thinning hair which is stress
hormones environment nutrition and
Metabolism through whole body health so
yes I am under the hormones category of
that and neutrophil is targeting those
things to help me be a thick-headed
queen
neutrophil has three unique formulas to
support women throughout all stages of
life including postpartum and menopause
each formula is physician formulated
using natural drug-free medical grade
ingredients inconsistently effective
dosage so you guys get the most reliable
results you can grow thicker healthier
hair and support our show by going to
neutrophone.com and entering the promo
code toast to save 15 off your first
month subscription this is their best
offer anywhere and it is only available
to us customers for a limited time
plus you'll get free shipping on every
order get 15 off at nutrifol.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code toast and
get your hair looking thick and right it
is the best stuff
okay next up we have a couple stories
about Megan and Harry because they were
in New York last night having you know a
movie moment uh on their glamorous night
in New York City they attended the
Robert F Kennedy Ripple of Hope award
Gala in the city they were honored with
the award for their work in racial
Justice mental health and other social
impact action through their archwell
Foundation also two days ago the trailer
for their new show dropped and there's
been a lot of backlash about the trailer
because they use a lot of stock footage
and stock images of Paparazzi you know
the narrators are saying how they're
being hounded by Paparazzi and then some
eagle-eyed viewers showed that the
footage of Paparazzi and cameras have
nothing to do with them they're from
Harry Potter Premiere they're from other
instances that weren't like these
weren't Paparazzi that were hounding
Megan and Harry so the story is a bit
twofold but they're in New York city so
have you gotten good tips about them
this week
I know where they're staying oh tell me
offline just curious I I was actually
really surprised at the I mean it's
probably
um you could figure it out by the
paparazzi pictures I think the paparazzi
pictures outside their hotel but I don't
want to say but I was surprised that
that's where they were staying it's more
of like a hip place not like they're not
staying at the plaza they're not staying
at like the Mark or the Carlisle that's
where I would expect them to stay me too
I was actually just talking about this
with Claudia yesterday not on the show
like where we think that they stay in
New York because I'm so curious I feel
like hotels in New York are either like
so historic and classic or they're like
you know new age you don't even check in
there's a robot and so I'm just curious
what their Vibe was but then I was
thinking they'd probably stay like at a
friend's house where they could be like
really secure but no they're at a hotel
they're at a hotel and that's also the
security issue like when I heard the
name of the hotel I was like I would
think like a Carlisle or a plaza would
have much more heightened security than
where they're staying so I was surprised
and I was wondering if it was was a
conscious decision to like be more cool
and hip the fact that they were staying
there I gotta know afterwards what hotel
it is and why I think that they might
stay there they might have also like
gotten a deal they might have gotten
like a whole floor for free and like now
they're you know working
people like the rest of us like you want
to say the buck yeah so I mean that's
all I really heard and you know I also
this was in the news but didn't people
recently quit
yeah production company I think I saw a
headline 14 people from their team over
the since they've like built their U.S
non-royal team have left
which is like a lot of people it is a
lot of people and you have to wonder why
like what's going on
um but yeah like all her all of their
deals like their Spotify deal and the
podcast like it took a long time for
that to get off the ground and running
right and I don't really have any
information why but I think that that's
suspect to me that's like weird yeah I
agree and I feel like especially with
the podcast they signed that Spotify
deal they didn't put out any content I
feel like it wasn't until they were kind
of
um called out by I think it was the post
being like it's been two years and we've
gotten like one 20-minute podcast
episode like what's going on with the uh
sussexes and Spotify that she started
her podcast Yes actually her podcast won
People's Choice podcast last night I
don't know if you I don't know if you
saw that I did see it I did see it and I
thought that that was probably I mean
let's be honest the People's Choice is
like rigged so you don't think it's the
People's Choice you don't think the
people are choosing no absolutely not
100 not I'm shocked I mean shocked they
picked the winners they probably was
hoping she would show up you know that's
why they picked those winners so but
listen her podcast is doing great like
people love it she has great guests
somebody told me that like don't be
surprised if she parlays this into like
an on-air hosting
situation like a daytime talk show sort
of thing yeah yeah somebody said that I
don't know if it was like inside
information or if it was just them
speculating but it made so much sense
that actually makes a lot of sense yeah
wow now I can't now I can't unsee it
listen she'd probably be really good at
it yeah um people love her people love
to hate her people just hate her
um but it's all all comes out in the
wash you know you're talking about it I
feel like daytime talk shows are really
hard to hide when they're not popular do
you know what I mean like I feel like
with podcasting it's pretty easy to make
it look like no one knows how many
listeners you have right how many lists
and especially even if I'm sure she has
a ton of listeners but it might not be
the number that people would expect from
her so I feel like
they're
there's more like there's more Security
in podcasting I feel like but I also
just love the medium yeah I mean listen
like I haven't checked the Apple charts
yet but usually I like check to see I'm
sure she's like up there well she's only
on Spotify charts and and so oh okay
Spotify exclusive shows chart High
because it's the only place you can
listen to them like it's it's all good
oh oh you're right duh Spotify duh okay
so she's not on the charts
she's not on the on the Apple charts
yeah yeah I don't ever check the Spotify
ones I only check Apple right I know
same
you guys are always on the charts thank
you I'd love to you yeah I bet you do I
like ask my age and I'm like how the
[ __ ] do I get on the charts and she's
like I don't know I don't know she's
like I'm like how many downloads do you
need per episode to get on the charts
but like the charts are a mixture I
think for people who have been
podcasting for years it's like pretty
uh like clear-cut you know the more
listeners you get the more higher you'll
be in the charts but for like newer
podcasts if you have like a trendy or
episode you'll Trend higher or if you're
a new podcast where there's like a lot
of Buzz right now like you will chart
really high but then you know everyone
when they launch a podcast they hit
number one and then everyone posts it
and then and then like let's talk in a
few months no yeah that no that happened
to me like when I launched I think I hit
like five or seven and then it like it
falls off and then yeah and then I just
check the episodes you know I like to
check the episode
um chart too it's really interesting I
think it's also very interesting to see
who charts and who doesn't yeah but even
like the chart is the reason why we're
obsessed with it is because we all we
it's all we have in terms of competitor
analytics right
because podcasting is really like OBS uh
not transparent you don't know what
people are doing
right you guys are you guys are always
on it everyone should know that I don't
know if your listeners checked the
charts but Round of Applause for you
guys number one what did you guys call
what did you guys call yourself do you
still say number one source for news
remember your tagline back in the day
the millennial morning show was what we
used to say before that it was like you
would say like the number one source for
this is like when you guys first started
you would say like the number one source
maybe it was for just news
interesting you don't remember maybe I
made it all no no I'm sure I'm I I
believe you like I wonder so many things
that like we would say like all the time
it's just funny how things morph without
you even noticing like we used to say
the millennial morning we used to like
really be the millennial Morning Show we
were like obsessed with being like a
pseudo Morning Show and now we're just
like we love podcasting we're like happy
to be comedy podcast that comes out
sometimes in the mornings yeah no you
guys are great also like you get great
guests you guys have like great
chemistry you have a really great
platform you should be proud of
yourselves it's not it's not easy people
should know it's not easy thank you so
much it's really sweet I feel like it
you have to like be a podcaster to
realize like how
um much goes into it and I think for
people who don't who are just like
listeners or just you know trolls uh
they think it's like oh you work one
hour a day how nice no not at all it's
like I mean I my podcast like I'm
working all week to like get content
from my podcast so yeah it's like
literally from like Monday until the
following Tuesday like trying to gather
information you know because
I try to make it exclusive content not
what's on Instagram so it makes it
harder but right it's so true I feel
like that was one thing that was really
interesting in your book was like the
early days of dumwan like what people
thought you might do with it you know
and like in the book there's someone who
like comes and tries to buy it pretty
early on that was true I believe that's
true and the way that like you talked
about the exchange like what the person
said like I totally like I'm so curious
what the media company was but I totally
believe that and now like knowing what
Dumas has turned into it's like that
offer is a low ball Beyond it was
lowball so I think they offered me I'll
tell you like they offered me 250 at
first for 25 and I was like are you
kidding me 25 is like a huge steak Yeah
for only 250 000 now that being said
like I had only been around I think like
a year and a half but I just thought
that the value in the brand was higher
so they were like they doubled it in the
end they winded up like
saying like we could double it but let's
discuss and I was just advised like this
is not a good move like you don't give
up 25 of your business that's like a lot
yeah especially when like there's so
much runway ahead of you right so I just
but I needed the help like I needed the
support which was like which was so
attractive to me because they were
offering me support right they were
offering me like their teams because it
was a it's an established media company
they were offering me their team to help
me grow my business and that was like so
attractive to me because I you know was
doing everything myself and I pretty
much still do so
but I winded up declining and the guy
kept coming back and coming back and he
knows he's in the book
and he said to me like he sent me a note
like laughing kind of like I can't
believe you put this in and I was like
well it is based on true events and this
really did happen so and he didn't
portray him unflatteringly no no no no
no and the whole thing with like I will
say like the whole thing with um Ollie
like betraying me with him that wasn't
true oh okay Ollie's in the business
like the real life Ali's in the business
but he's in a different facet of the
business so they would never
be interacting in real life
got it I'm like very cool get the behind
the scenes T even though the book is all
the behind the scenes tea really yeah
um okay before we move on from Megan and
Harry so do you get a lot of tips about
them like yeah Vibe yeah so I get a lot
of tips or I get a lot of requests for
tips and I always say that like I'm
really trepidatious about like posting
about her because she has so many like
very passionate fans who will be very
quick to call you like a misogynist and
racist if you say the wrong thing and
like the wrong thing could be like I
hate her dress like they'll be like
upset that you said that so it's not
worth for me like posting but yeah I've
heard like so much [ __ ] about her like
all the horror stories about like her
you know being not great I've heard that
I don't know if it's true you know I
think she has like a huge cross to bear
in her position so I give her a little
bit of like Grace yeah she's difficult I
understand that yeah because she can't
be in the easiest situation it has to be
hard yeah in her situation aside from
like the Megan and Harry T do you have
people in the palace who give you just
like who are one fans or two like just
tell you maybe like random [ __ ] about
what goes on yeah there was somebody who
was like really close to like the Royals
that was giving me a lot of information
but then I started to realize that it
was skewed against Harry and Megan which
makes sense because the Royals don't
like them yeah
um so I was like hmm like maybe I should
talk to somebody who's less biased but
let me tell you something there's nobody
out there that's not biased they're
either Royals or Harry and Megan that's
what it is it's extremely like the two
sides are very clear it's very hard to
like Walk the Line in between and if
anyone could did it was the queen and
she's passed rest in peace my queen all
right pay yeah are you do you are you
like a royalist do you watch it do you
love the queen or are you just like
don't care no I don't care
yeah yeah no same
me either so I honestly they care you
just gave everyone another clue that
you're Claudia Claudia like won't
Claudia has like barred me from talking
about any really Royal news unless it's
like
the biggest deal like I can't talk about
my new stories anymore that I think
people would find fascinating no they
love it but I'm just like I don't live
there like why do I care like a lot of
people feel that way yeah yeah like why
do I care but people care and I'm all
for supporting the people that care I
just am not one of them have you ever
thought about doing like branching out
Dumas like internationally like having
to run other places and probably having
like someone else be that person yes so
people ask me all the time can I start a
demois Brazil can I start a demois
Broadway can I start a demois sports and
my answer is yes but like I needed to be
official so I would have to like hire
someone to do that that's a lot yeah
that's a lot of faith to put in someone
else to like take your brand and like
license it and I'm sure at the end of
the day it's almost nearly impossible to
verify
that yeah so I just like I would love
that to be part of like the future
business plan but it's just not in the
near future I would need like a team and
it's very hard for me to trust people so
which is why I'm like riding solo still
because I I don't know like it's hard to
trust people I feel like yeah I'm sure
you're lucky because you work with your
sisters and your sister and it's like
you don't who do you trust more than
that I know we talk about it all the
time like how fortunate we feel like I
mean that there is that implicit level
of trust there's no like one day with
one of us who run away with the show
like yeah
it's it's very nice also I feel like
that was another theme in your book like
you never really thought about like how
isolating it could maybe feel to have
this like big secret and that constantly
is making you be on your phone and you
have all of these things going on in
your brain and then like when you talk
to someone that aren't like your close
friends like you can't talk about like
the biggest thing in your life right so
like that's that's very you nailed it
again like it is very isolating which is
why like I started to open up a little
bit like we could tell people like my
camera's on like we could see each other
like I don't want to be like isolated
like it's not a great feeling like I've
started meeting more people in person
that like I'm talking to like for
business purposes not like you know just
for fun yeah um because it it it's been
an isolating two years and it's not it
doesn't feel good it feels sad you know
so I want to Branch out a little more I
think that's great and I think you're
going about it in a really good way and
people just like are obsessed with you
and whatever bit of yourself that you
want to give I like I'm sure it's
amazing I'm sure also podcasting is a
great way for you to just like get it
out and talk about what you're doing I
mean I don't really talk about myself
personally like I'm never like okay this
weekend I went to such and such place
like I'm not like that type of podcaster
I keep it like strictly business I'm
like let's get into the topics like I
don't know if people want to hear from
me personally like I don't think they do
so I just keep my mouth shut but it's
not because I'm trying to hide it's just
because I don't think they care you know
what I mean right right well you could
always test it out but I feel like even
having a place where you can like go and
talk about like what's happening on
dumois with a larger audience yes it's a
release that I didn't have before it's
great which is why I'm like I can't wait
till this episode comes out because I'm
going to direct everyone who's messaging
me about Ariel charnis to listen to this
episode because it's so much easier to
talk through it than just post it and
like to write like a written statement I
I need I like to talk to I feel that way
so many people will be like a message me
on Instagram like why are you talking
about Balenciaga and it's like girl I
went not a [ __ ] tirade every single
day this week on the toast like just go
listen like listen exactly it's easier
to talk through things than post and you
know when I first started my podcast
people would be like stop directing
people to listen to your podcast like
post it on Instagram and I'm like I
can't post everything on Instagram it's
it's not it's not enhancing your
experience also by me just writing
things out like listen to us talk it
through and I'll I'll wind up telling
more on the podcast yep than on
Instagram 100 easier so and you're more
comfortable more comfortable exactly
totally okay well moving on to the next
Story the time 2022 person of the year
is here there was a short list of nine
people that I think they released like
yesterday but the person of the year is
not Kelly Clarkson unfortunately for me
it is Vladimir valenski zielinski of the
Ukraine
oh that's nice for him yeah that is nice
for him and feels very apt for the year
uh it's interesting I didn't realize I
was looking at last year's winner which
was Elon Musk and some years they give a
list of everyone who was nominated and
other years they don't this year they
gave the list of nine people last year
there was no runner-up to Elon
wait was Kelly on the list no no I'm
kidding she's just she's just my person
of the year every year no I I would
believe it I mean people love her she
seems great like she she like is killing
her talk show like right yeah she's like
bringing people together that's just
like who I would have nominated but they
had other plans in mind does she know
you're such a big fan of hers I don't
think so but I'm one of those people
it's not that I don't want to meet my
heroes because I don't think that
they'll be disappointing and I
definitely don't think Kelly would be
disappointing I just like like to admire
something like I just like to be a fan
sometimes same yeah right yeah I don't
want to meet anyone who wait who who's
been your most favorite celebrity that
you've ever met oh that I've ever met
because you guys have done like red
carpets you've been to a ton of events
you've been in the you've been doing
this for so long like that's so true
well I feel like of celebrities who I've
met and I'm a huge fan of and like
together it's been a great experience
like Luke Combs oh okay I knew you were
gonna say someone country
and we really get like a good read on
people there like we've had some amazing
changes with people and especially in
country music like they are extremely
relaxed on a red carpet so it's just fun
um and we've also had some like awkward
celebrity encounters too enough for me
to make me realize like I don't need to
meet everyone I can just sometimes be a
fan like the work a lot of times people
are not their character on the show that
you like and that's okay yes I agree
with that 100 yeah
so
all right Luke Combs Luke Combs maybe
for solid answer next for person of the
year do you meet any celebrities like as
do mois no I haven't I'm sure they would
like [ __ ] their pants I haven't I've
been in their presence but I haven't I
haven't like said hi like I'm demo and
like I've talked about this before like
I sat next to Lindsay Hubbard from
summer house at a restaurant and we DM
so like I could have easily like she
would have known like who I was
um and then I also sat next to like a
table of celebrities at Carbone it was
like Mark Ronson Samantha Ronson Grace
Gummer
Carol radziwell Cassandra gray they were
all eating at Carbone and I was like a
table away and I've dm'd with some of
those people at that table so I was like
oh [ __ ]
oh yeah that but I never told them yeah
I never told them I get that do you
think that maybe going forward like you
might do more of that as you venture out
or that's like no I think like I would
like meet like other creators like I
would
you know meet you or Claudia or like you
know other creators that I've had on my
podcast who have developed a
relationship with but not celebrities
like
yeah but not celebrities I that makes
sense and it really is nice talking to
other people who do some like uh things
that are akin to what you do and because
some of the just the like random
struggles that go along with the work
it's fun to have people to like talk
about their experiences that's so true
especially since like I work alone like
I love like talking to you about like
podcasting or like
whatever you know yeah that's so true
it's really really fun do you have like
the craziest DMS with celebrities like
with people die if they knew who like
talks to you directly and like who you
just like chat with
um I think they'd be surprised about
some of the people for sure
um but like you know there's some like
huge A-list celebrities that like I've
dm'd for various reasons who've like not
even opened my DM or
responded for example like John Mayer
I've dm'd like tons of times now it's
just like a joke because like I heard
that he liked shrimp cocktail so like
whenever I'm like at a restaurant and
Order shrimp cocktail because I also
love shrimp cocktail like I'll send him
a picture of the shrimp cocktail and be
like thinking of you so now I'm just
like like you know spamming him with
shrimp cocktail picks but I think that
yeah I think some of the people people
would be like that's so Random yeah like
Kim Kardashian was on a podcast once and
she said she has a finsta and she uses
it to check to Moi yeah I wonder I don't
know if she's messaged me from it she
could have messaged me from it and been
sending me tips I have no idea oh my God
yeah or like you might not have even
seen it if it was just like right an
account with a couple followers right I
there's so Aaron Lim from E she admitted
that she sends me tips via a finsta and
she says that I have never responded to
her and she said I probably read her
messages and like this person's batshit
crazy
to which I say
the stuff that's the craziest is always
the stuff that's the most true so she
could be like sending me all these tips
and I'm probably like this person's so
crazy and not responding right and also
if it's a fin stem sure that you take it
that with a grain of salt as opposed to
someone who's willing to put their face
behind a tit 100 that's part of my
vetting process but you'd be surprised
there are some fences that have like
surfaced that have very specific
information on things and I'm like hmm
okay
all right I see what you're doing like
you're really trying to hide like who
you are so it depends it depends
interesting yeah okay well our next
story is last night's People's Choice
Awards which Dumas says are not the
People's Choice
um we have the complete list of winners
I don't know how much people care but
I'll just go through the big categories
move the best movie of 2022 according to
the people is Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness sure whatever
that's such a lie that's like literally
not have I have not heard of this movie
I would have said the movie of the year
was Top Gun agree
uh or even don't worry darling because
Olivia Wilde was there or Elvis I loved
Elvis yeah I think that that's total
planted BS
and didn't Elvis Austin Butler and the
girl who played Priscilla oh I forgot
her name but she's also in the society
have a little fling on set yeah Olivia
De Jeong I think her name is yeah yeah
yeah yeah supposedly they did have a
little fling I don't know if it
overlapped with his relationship with
Vanessa
um but that's what people think I don't
know Austin Butler like great guy but a
little bit of a grifter
oh or was a grifter how so
I mean I just heard that he was like
grifting off of Vanessa Hudgins like
living in her house or maybe she bought
him a house like something like that you
know what I mean and like at the time
when they dated she was much more famous
than him right and now he he got to
where he was trying to go
yeah and now he's dating Kaya although I
think they're I think they're broken up
she was seen making out and you know
this will be a morning toast exclusive I
will reveal
um she was seen making out with that
bazzi
yeah so she was seen making out with him
a couple weeks ago at an event and
somebody wrote in and then somebody who
who was at the event also confirmed it
somebody who was like blue check mark
was there saw it so she wasn't hiding
oh wow hang out with him so I don't know
if him her and Austin are done I kind of
ship those two he makes amazing music I
never saw a picture of him and he's
looks very cute yeah I've never heard
one of his songs you have you got one
that's like I have the worst voice but
here I go singing for dumwa
hey beautiful beautiful beautiful
beautiful
angel I love your imperfections every
angle you know that one
oh
but that sounds just like him when I
sang it I appreciate like I appreciate
how hard you tried it you tried to sing
that no I don't know it but he's like
cute you know what I was wondering like
what is your taste in music what was
your Spotify wrapped
um well I don't use Spotify I use apple
I'm sorry I don't know I know um it was
the first it was Counting Crows that was
the album I listened to the most
oh my God that's the headline stand so
have you ever gotten like a a bad tip
about counting crowsing or like I will
protect them till the end
foreign
not yet but maybe now I'm well I don't
know I mean somebody said somebody said
um I posted this on Twitter it was like
Counting Crows and then it was like my
top music genres were like alternative
hip-hop like adult alternative pop or
something and somebody was like I could
spot a millennial like when I see one
and I'm like listen I love the Counting
Crows it's just like emo 90s music I'm
really into like emo 90s music but no I
haven't heard one bad thing about the
Counting Crows please nobody send me in
any bad tips about the Counting Crows
please my number [ __ ] funny number
one Listen to album like I don't know
how many minutes it like tells you how
many minutes you've listened you know
it's depressing I'm like I don't need to
know that I've listened to the Counting
Crows for 1700 minutes like or however
that's so funny do you get a lot of tips
about people especially there are so
many celebrities in general there's so
many up and I mean there's so many
different tiers of celebrities you get
like a lot of tips about people and
you're like I don't know who the [ __ ]
this is yes everyone I had a Google
bazzi I didn't know who bazzi was true I
have no idea that's like a perfect
example yeah there's a lot of people
that I don't know and there's also a lot
of like C and d-list celebrities that
people want to know about that I'm like
it's so true who they are there and
there are so many like Niche audiences
which is why it does make sense to like
maybe one day like do do more Broadway
like even do my influencers I also feel
like you can't talk about influencers
because if you did it would open up the
floodlight your stories would be triple
the length because there are so many
influencers people who identify as
influencers like because it can be
really any size and also if you're again
if you're in New York and you're an
influencer chances are that you have
interacted with
hundreds and hundreds of people so I'll
that's why the more somebody's out there
the more tips I get about them right so
like I don't know who's like reclusive
right now Miley Cyrus is like super
reclusive right now I haven't heard one
thing about Miley Cyrus in months right
but then you just said that she's coming
back soon yeah I did say that she has
new music coming out very soon
um I think at the end of this year which
is in a couple weeks or maybe the
beginning of next
um I wonder what she's been up to just
like recording and chilling and like
hiding like yeah like good they know how
not to be seen that's why like these
celebrities that like go to Craigs or go
to Carbone it's like they know what
they're doing yeah oh totally do you
know what I mean so are there
celebrities that are just like too small
like you're like I don't care about this
person yeah because I'm just like yeah
because I don't want to like I don't
want to throw off like you know
throw off the audience like if I'm like
posting like Selena Timothy chalamet
like Tom Cruise and then all of a sudden
it's like some sealless celebrity from
like you know big brother yeah and
people are like what
um so I try to just like avoid them like
I know like love is blind and that other
show what's that other show love Island
like something love Island yeah those
are really popular but I don't watch
them so I I don't know when people
message me the names I'm like I have no
idea who these people are and you won't
post something like that if it's
something that's like big news and it's
about one of those two shows
I will but they have to explain to me
why this is big news like they would
have to say like they broke up and now
they're back together so and so cheated
like do you know what I mean otherwise
yeah I'm lost and I'm not about to watch
like Four Seasons of Love is Blind or
however many seasons there are no I
totally feel that do you watch any TV
like for Dumont like so that you can be
up to speed on stuff or it's just like
what you watch and what you're
interested in
um I would say like 70 of like what I
watch and what I'm interested in but
then there'll be like a show that people
will keep messaging me about being like
you have to watch the show right you
have to watch the show and I'm like okay
I'm gonna watch this show and I wind up
actually really liking those shows that
my audience recommends or they'll be
like they're so cute they'll be like I
know you'll love this show like this
show is up your alley because they see
all the shows that I'm like talking
about and posting about so I take their
recommendations very seriously so yes I
will do that okay yeah that makes sense
especially since these days like one
some things like one series
it's like a long movie and it's very
enjoyable especially and everything's
like made so well yeah did you like I'm
curious did you like don't worry darling
I didn't watch it oh okay uh but I've
heard good things I might watch it one
day I just like do I don't have the time
to sit and watch a movie because I have
a baby and he's like then when I do have
a few hours it's like I don't want to
watch a movie that feels like a real
movie like I just wanna I like wanna
read or something like I probably maybe
I'll watch it around the holidays
because it seems like a good movie to
watch like with your family yeah I mean
it's so hard to like find dark it's a
little dark oh is it what do you think I
loved it I thought that like all of the
rumors about like Florence Pugh carrying
the movie weren't true I thought all the
actors did a great job I thought Olivia
Wilde's performance was really good
Chris Pine people making fun of Harry's
performance like totally unwarranted I
thought he did a great job I thought it
was an interesting movie I I didn't all
the hate it received regarding like the
plot and whatnot
I mean there were a lot of plot holes
but I still enjoyed it I thought it was
okay unwanted hate I had heard good
things also it was the drama movie of
2022. I know from The People's Choice
that one I believe I believe that the
category though there are some like
strong choices like where the crawdads
saying luckiest girl alive Elvis death
on the Nile which wasn't very good but
it was it was cute
um and some other movies but I believe
that too and Olivia Wilde showed up so I
think that's worth giving it to her for
well maybe they were like if we give you
this award will you show up and she was
like yeah yeah because how do you beat
first of all what the Crawdad thing was
so good so depressing but like so good I
know and then wait what was the second
one you said not luckiest girl alive
luckiest girl alive obsessed yeah also
so good very dark
um but yeah maybe they just were like if
you show up we'll give you this and she
was like I'll do it for the people
for the people she's a woman of the
people what would be a while she is now
yeah which is actually surprising that
she showed up too I know which is like
so surprised I would say it's like a c
tier award show I would say she's like
an A-list yeah celebrity especially
these days and I I'm always surprised
when she keeps putting herself in these
situations for like people to have so
much access to her that is so true but
maybe like that's her like way maybe
that's her PR crisis like strategy which
is actually genius it is because we keep
just the news cycle keeps changing with
her and I think that's probably what
she's looking for yes
smart moves our fifth and final story is
brought to you by Shopify which is such
a great sponsor for today's episode
because it makes being a business owner
so much easier and it makes it really
accessible if you're thinking about
starting a business you don't know where
to start Shopify that's the answer
Shopify makes it simple to sell to
anyone from anywhere whether your thing
is vintage cheese or recipes for ghee or
sickening merch that you can get at
toastmerch.com start selling with
Shopify and join the platform
simplifying Commerce for millions of
your favorite businesses worldwide with
Shopify you'll create an online store in
your Vibe discover new customers and
grow the following that keeps them
coming back Shopify has all the sales
channels sorted so your business keeps
growing from an in-person POS system to
all-in-one e-commerce platform even
across social media platforms like Tick
Tock Facebook and Instagram and thanks
to 24 7 support and free libraries full
of educational content shopify's got you
every step of the way it's how every
minute new sellers around the world are
making their first sale with Shopify and
you will too wow while I've been doing
this ad people are making their first
sales today and I just want to say you
go girls and boys chase that dream make
that coin it's never been easier to
start your business and grow it thanks
to Shopify we always have loved being
business owners but platforms like
Shopify I think Shopify is the number
one platform that we use that has made
it so easy to live out our dreams of
being Moguls mogul's Moguls I think
shopify's new slogan should be Shopify
Mogul Tings but you know they didn't ask
me for a slogan nevertheless she
persisted okay when you're ready to
launch your thing into the spotlight do
it with Shopify the Commerce platform
backing millions of businesses down the
street and around the globe go on try
Shopify for free and start selling
anywhere
sign up for a free trial at shopify.com
toast all lowercase toast by the way go
to shopify.com toast and lowercase to
start selling online today shopify.com
toast check it out if you're someone
who's like thinking about starting your
own business one let this ad be assigned
for you to start it with Shopify and two
let this episode with two female
creators be your sign it is your time go
chase your dream
um so there were a bunch of other
winners last night congratulations to
everyone the only really big news that
happened was Kathy Kathy Hilton putting
her lipstick on as Marishka Hargitay was
accepting her award and people are
quaking that's just so Kathy it's so
Kathy like she doesn't know what's going
on like I wonder if did you know that
the um lawn Order SVU show has a crazy
fan base did you yeah and Claudia ashrae
is their number one feature she is
obsessed she talks about happily about a
Law and Order she finds a way to like
talk about a law in Order episode once
an episode probably on the show they're
they're crazy they try to like convince
me that Mariska and um what's his name
uh Stabler are like together in real
life they hate mariska's husband in real
life like oh that's [ __ ] vile he's
literally the most amazing man in
Hollywood he's someone who we had on the
show Once and we met and I would say
like he's one of my favorite celebrities
we've ever met sing it sister they need
to hear it because like they like do not
like him for some reason oh my God
they're not okay he's not only the most
handsome man period he also is in all
the best movies and shows like he's
Charles from younger he his IMDb is like
all amazing movies and then him and
Marisha like have this gorgeous marriage
it's too much he actually just um
directed an episode of and just like
that
oh wow and just like that it's like so
similar to younger kind of just because
they're like New York City shows yeah so
he you're right he does have like a
really robust resume but yeah they don't
like them so I wonder if they're mad at
Kathy now like I'm really curious about
like oh if they're pissed that Kathy
like disrespected their Queen like that
I need to know that is so so funny yeah
have you heard good things about like
the two of them orishka and Peter yeah
well sometimes the fans will trick me
and they'll send in a blind item because
I didn't know about this fan base and
sometimes I forget about them but
they'll send in a blind item through
email and they'll they'll paint him in a
bad light sometimes they'll paint her in
a bad light like sometimes they'll say
like her and Stabler were seen like
canoodling so sometimes they trick me
but then then the people that really
know the truth will DM me and be like
none of this is true so yes I've only
heard like pretty like good things about
her she seems really intimidating in
real life but I think she's warm I think
she's a warm person but she seems nice
she could be intimidating have you ever
met her no I don't think so I I could
see that too that she's probably worn
but it's just an intimidating person
because she's like so accomplished but
they're also a New York City couple so
I'm surprised you don't get more like
spotting I I know I do sometimes like at
dinners and stuff but you know nothing
like there's no really like there's no
Goss about them like people any Goss I
post if it falls through the cracks like
going forward know that it's fake and I
made a mistake because they're just like
you said a normal couple
who love each other and have a great
marriage that's so beautiful what are do
you think are some of the people
celebrities or like shows
whatever it is that have the craziest
fan base oh my god well Selena Gomez
um her fan base was mad at me yesterday
because I posted a picture of somebody
who I thought was Selena with Dylan
O'Brien and they're like you're so
[ __ ] stupid that's not Selena that's
some Brazilian influencer her name is
such and such people were messaging me
like you're pathetic I'm like you're
really oh my God I'm really mad because
I misidentified
like like that's that's what you're mad
about um she has won okay ones that you
wouldn't expect
um Lauren Graham has a lovely fan base
they're very polite and so nice every
time I post the sighting of her they'll
be like thank you so much we were
worried about her like they're so
thankful and polite
um Dakota Johnson has a crazy fan base
from 50 Shades I think maybe that's
surprising yeah
um and who else oh Robert Pattinson not
surprising crazy fan base they hate Suki
they're always trying to tell me their
PR and that like the their they call the
paparazzi you know they're always trying
to convince me of that
um I'm trying to think like any obscure
ones the law and order one yeah there's
like that is pretty obscure yeah there's
like some crazy obscure ones
um that if I when I encounter I'm like
this is great
because it's so interesting
it is interesting and I that's fun to
think about
our fifth and final story well you know
who has the craziest fan base of all the
real housewife fans and Jackie gold
Schneider has just given them content
for days so Ed Survivor Jackie
goldschneider blast Bethenny Frankel
skinny girl she said [ __ ] you Jackie
gold Schneider who has been open about
her lifelong struggles with an eating
disorder is calling out Bethany
frankfelt for creating a brand marketed
after a thin female physique she said
quote Bethany has skinny well so she was
on this virtual reality T podcast live
taping at City Winery last night and a
question was asked about like skinny
girl there's Tipsy girl like cheater
brand thing
and Jackie golden said quote Bethany has
skinny girl and I've got a very strong
opinion on this one because I say [ __ ]
marketing skinny I'm sick of [ __ ]
marketing skinny I don't want to drink
something because it's going to keep me
skinny so [ __ ] you Bethany [ __ ] your
skinny brand that's how I feel
um wow and then yeah which is it was a
really strong statement do you watch all
like these Housewives oh yeah I'm like
deep into New York and New Jersey
um I thought I think she's not wrong
that's just a very aggressive response
but I think Bethany deserves it like
she's so abrasive and aggressive lately
so I'm happy to see someone giving it
back
totally I agree like the she's not wrong
it was like a very strong statement but
that's actually exactly how Bethany
would speak about a brand that she felt
that way about so let's see where what
Bethany responds to this it's just
someone like kind of like going Toe to
Toe with her and giving a taste of her
own medicine no I totally agree and she
actually back to Fan basis she has a
crazy fan base do you see how they will
defend her on Tick Tock do you ever read
the comments Bethany you know you know
I'm not on Tick Tock oh okay you're
smart
um
you guys Claudia post like the cutest
tick tocks of you guys yeah so she I
used to have a tick tock it's still
there it's literally like perfect me
doing the Renegade like back in the day
um but then I deleted it a few years ago
and like now I won't one I can't get
back into my account so if you know what
I'm on Tick Tock I just do want access
to my account and two I just I don't
have enough time to to lose that amount
of time in Tick Tock and I feel like
you're smart some of this stuff that
people people are watching like some of
it's cool hacks and interesting facts
but some of it is so [ __ ] dumb and I
need to preserve my few brain cells that
are left but I do spend a lot of time on
Instagram I feel like maybe if I had
Tick Tock I would spend less time on
Instagram but I'm glad that I actually
really like Tick Tock because people
Love the clips from the show they always
like say really funny things in the
comments I literally will have Claudia
screenshot me comment sections so it's
like um I see what goes on but in terms
of things that are trending or what
Bethany's doing on Tick Tock I have no
[ __ ] clue yeah the comments are the
best part of Tick Tock but if you look
at anyone listening I'm sure your
audience is like plugged into this
Bethany's comments like they defend her
like they will stand up for anything she
does no matter how [ __ ] up it is and I
think that she's been very mouthy lately
and it's turned me off personally like
I've never been a huge Bethany fan but I
always just kind of enjoyed her on the
show and I like to follow her career I
think she's a smart businesswoman but
she's been very polar Rising lately and
they'll defend it it's crazy
yeah oh I didn't realize so many people
were defending her because all I see is
like all the headlines where it's like
the people who speak out against her or
who she's coming for and I feel like
most people are not here for it but I
guess her fans are still intact yeah and
I also want to know like who she
who's she getting at Page Six
like literally multiple headlines a day
like I don't like show review a
blueberry muffin and they'll be like
Bethany says blueberry muffins suck and
that'll be like the headline and it's
like what like she's smart but she must
know someone there that's giving her all
this exposure oh that's so funny that's
like Kelly Ripa and People magazine and
Hello magazine we call it Kelly's
mindless news because like literally
Kelly ripo will post a picture of her
carpet and it's like Kelly Ripa not even
her carpet the carpet's in like the
corner of the picture of herself and
it's like Kelly Ripa's gorgeous new
carpet like get all the details and it's
like if you actually went to the picture
it's not even in there so yeah she is
plugged in somehow well I feel like with
People magazine like they really go by
what Their audience responds to so they
must have an audience that's like super
into Kelly Ripa do you know what I mean
because like I you know I'll talk to
people at People magazine and I'll it's
interesting to see like who what
celebrities like they'll post they'll
post or write about what celebrities
they won't only because their audience
is not into them so that is very
interesting so you're saying it's the
People's Choice People magazine is is
actually the People's Choice yes that is
like they do like crazy human interest
stories that Claudia and I love and I
feel like those really do get a lot of
clicks yeah no they do so that's that's
like why they're probably posting Kelly
Ripa but like as far as Bethany and Page
Six like maybe it's the same case for
her over at page six but I just I don't
see it like I I sometimes they put they
report on things that are just like dumb
when it comes to yeah
that's so interesting there's a couple
other like I feel like also like Demi
Rose and Daily Mail yeah like she's
always in the Daily Mail it's like who
is she no I know that yeah that's
probably someone that does really well
for them like did you guys like when
Bethany went off on her Kardashian Rants
and whatnot did you guys cover that or
yes we did Claudia felt so strongly
about it like she was like [ __ ] off
Bethany like like
because we love the Kardashians yeah
most of the time
um I and I disagreed with what Bethany
said but like I kind of like that she
like takes a hard stand sometimes even
if it's not where I would plant my feet
like it's interesting and it's really
extra I just don't know what the goal is
because I feel like she's alienating so
many people and she knows it but it must
be doing well for her because she keeps
doing it exactly like that's what's so
interesting it's like why does she keep
doing it I think she went really hard on
them for no reason like exactly like she
could have her opinions but she could
have said it in a different way I don't
think she needed to be like so
aggressive and like I love that they
like didn't even respond of course they
didn't like you know of course no it was
[ __ ] awesome like what did she want
like did she want to like go back and
forth with the Kardashians in the media
like what what did she think was gonna
happen or has she seen that like going
viral in this way is good for her
business it must be because otherwise
like what are you doing I mean I I just
I guess my my mind does not like work
like that like do you guys like try to
say shocking things to go back yeah
never and anytime we like have like a
shot like I feel like I'm always saying
whatever is unpopular like and it's not
like I do it just to like start some
stuff it's like I just because I feel
like that's what needs to be said even
if it probably maybe shouldn't be and
I'm gonna get my ass handed to me no I
feel like you guys are like pretty like
organically open about like your
opinions and feelings but like with her
like it has to be calculated just like
you were saying I don't know it's very
interesting it's a very interesting
business model in my opinion I'd like to
I'd like to know more about it I don't
think she would ever be forthcoming
obviously like how she operates but
there has to be a reason behind it it
can't just be her ranting right or she's
like made all the money that she needs
to make she's happy in her life and she
feels this need to say what's on her
mind
guess I mean I don't know like is she I
don't know she's still making a lot of
money
I don't know I love that skinny girl
popcorn I'll always get it at the
supermarket I have to say that when the
skinny girl
um Margarita came out I consumed many
many bottles it was really good I
haven't seen it lately I don't know if
it's still as popular as it was but it
was so good do you remember when it came
out it was like I do that was like her
first thing yeah it was so good but now
she does all sorts of food like
dressings everything like they're skinny
girl for everything more than she even I
think promotes she has her skinny girl
jeans she had the big shot with Bethany
she's got like a lot of other stuff I
don't know I think she said somewhere
that skinny girl jeans is like her most
profitable thing about something yeah
yeah she's on like QVC or HSN I could
totally see that
well good for her
yeah I'm sure she'll be I am sure she
will be responding to Jackie gold
Schneider though
oh God you're right on tick tock on Tick
Tock yeah
yeah so those were the past five stories
I absolutely feel like you needed to
know them and you needed to know them
from dumwa and including all of the
other bits and pieces of stories that we
might have not received otherwise yeah I
mean thank you for I I didn't know the
Time person of the year so that was news
to me
that's what we do here we're just always
sharing things that you that you need to
know and that you might not hear
anywhere else yeah I didn't hear that
anywhere else so thank you for uh you
didn't get a tip that that he was the
front runner no no
I didn't thank you thank you so so much
for joining me you guys Zuma's book is
out now it's called a non-please and it
is Loosely and closely based off of her
story about how she became dumois how
the account started I feel like that's a
Like An Origin story people are always
wondering like why is it called dumois
but it's just as the book said like a
fancy bit of French that sounds nice
yeah exactly it's a fancy bit of French
that sounds nice it's a made-up word
which
it's totally a made-up word which like
in retrospect like was probably the
smartest thing because no one can yeah
like I was copying someone else or and
now it is like a word unto itself like
Google oh I'm so sorry someone's no
that's perfect timing that's at my door
oh have a great visitor and thank you so
much for joining us you guys you can
follow Juma at Dumont obviously and
listen to her podcast and check out her
book and then soon hopefully a TV show
so we will see you tomorrow Claudia it
was great chatting with you again
anything else that you would like to
promote before you go um no just the
book the link is in my bio please please
buy it selling a book is is no [ __ ]
joke I've said this before it's not like
selling a sweatshirt selling a book is
hard I heard you had some influence so
thank you for promoting it you're so
welcome yes I love to read and you know
what this book is perfect for this time
of year like this is a beach read if
you're going on vacation and you want a
book that you can just like tear through
it's a non-please yeah people have read
it in like hours
yeah yeah it's it's that kind of book
which is so great that's my favorite
kind of book honestly yeah um I also
have a collab out right now with Mayfair
a merch collab I saw a sickening stuff
yes thank you it's actually going to be
my last merch drop for a while so if you
guys are interested
um information's on my Instagram and
podcast every Thursday do you it's
called
do you I love that dude you
okay thank you so so much bye dude bye
see ya see ya